SCOTT LANG
A lot has changed about my life.
We literally saved the world.
But right now, the only
job I want is being a dad.
♪♪
KANG THE CONQUEROR
Scott Lang...
You want to get out of here...
...and I need to get out of here.
Bring me what I want.
SCOTT LANG
What's that?
♪ When are you gonna come down? ♪
JANET VAN DYNE
You cannot trust him.
♪ When are you going to land? ♪
SCOTT LANG
I don't care who this guy is.
I just lost so much time.
♪ Oh, I've finally decided my future lies ♫
JANET VAN DYNE
He's a monster who thinks he's a god.
♪♪
KANG THE CONQUEROR
Everything you call a life...
CASSIE LANG
Dad!
KANG THE CONQUEROR
...I will burn out of time.
[Screaming]
SCOTT LANG
He's got Cassie.
HOPE VAN DYNE
We'll stop him together.
KANG THE CONQUEROR
You think you can beat me?
[Screaming]